OK.
Let's get right into audience questions for
the week.
First one is, hey, David, we've seen all sorts
of different takes and plans from Donald Trump
to governors about how and when states could
start to reopen after the virus.
What should a reasonable reopening America
plan look like?
So a couple of things on this.
Number one, I don't have any independent knowledge
in the sense that I believe we should trust
medical experts and public health experts
on this.
And so I'm going by what those individuals
are saying.
Not by what politicians are saying.
I think there's one other element to this
that's important.
In an ideal world, we would have done sort
of like a full shut down probably around February
20.
It could have gone to four months and it would
have been over this week and we would be in
much better shape right now.
Hindsight is 20/20, but the point is there
is a limited political willingness to continue
expending political capital as the protests
mount and the demands mount, as crazy as the
demands of the protesters are, as irrelevant
as those demands are to public health issues.
The reality is the pressure is going to grow
and it's not going to be possible to open
nothing.
So I'm starting from the point of not what
is or would have been the safest.
But what makes sense, given that the pressure
to reopen at least parts of society will only
continue to grow.
No one is testing now.
I'm not going to get into the full back and
forth about how Donald Trump initially took
took credit for testing, even though the testing
was terrible.
He would insist that it's all him now, that
it's clear the testing is not up to par to
reopen.
Trump is saying governors have to figure out
this testing thing.
Let's ignore the shirking of responsibility
for a moment.
We don't have enough testing.
We need, at a bare minimum, five hundred thousand
tests today.
More.
Most roadmaps say we need more, including
like a million tests today.
Remember that with a million tests today,
it still takes you almost a year to test everybody.
One roadmap says we need 22 million tests
today so you can test everybody on a rolling
14 day roughly basis.
Certainly five hundred or six hundred thousand
tests a day must be in place.
But not only that, you need proper contact
tracing infrastructure in Massachusetts.
Here, they've been hiring work from home,
contact tracers.
Different health systems have been doing it.
I think it pays around twenty five dollars
an hour.
Work from home.
All states need to be hiring proper contact
tracers so that you increase testing as you
test a lot of people as soon as you get a
positive test.
Contact tracing comes in and lets individuals
that may have been in contact with that infected
person know so that they can quarantine then
all the stuff about phases.
I'm not going to go piece by piece through
Donald Trump's proposal because I've already
done it.
But a few thoughts on that.
Number one, there won't be a light switch
that's flipped.
And we are back on some of the earlier things
that should happen include what retail elements
can start to be opened up somewhat so that
they can recover some of their revenue.
Remember, we've got the paycheck protection
plan.
But the money ran out.
So there's a ton of restaurants and other
retail facing businesses that risk going completely
out of business.
What can be done in restaurants in terms of
can people sit at tables, outback very much
spaced out so that they feel like they've
had a dining experience, but the bag of food
is placed on the table as if it were takeout.
There's no interaction with the waitstaff.
Would that make people feel as though we're
moving in the right direction, even though
in practice it wouldn't change that much about
the risk exposure?
I don't know.
I'm just sort of thinking out loud here.
Schools this semester should not reopen.
It just doesn't make any sense.
We should focus on shooting for the fall,
but being prepared to do the fall online.
People who can work from home and who work
office jobs where a lot of the work is e-mail
and phones should not go back to work anytime
soon.
We should keep as many people home as is possible
to lower the risk of loosening up some of
the public elements.
Jim's probably can't open right away.
I know that that was included in phase one
of Trump's plan.
Does not seem reasonable.
Seems like just an absolute cesspool of germs.
And even if you maintain social distancing
in gyms, I don't see how you avoid gyms becoming
a center of spread.
While we have cases and we probably can't
really loosen travel anytime soon either.
So for me, the the immediate loose innings
would be we start to let people get back to
being a little bit social.
Ideally, what we're talking about is, you
know, a couple that's been self isolating
and another couple that's been self isolating.
Get together in a.
House and everybody.
You don't shake hands, but you can hang out
a couple of hours.
That probably would be like a next step as
cases go down.
Again, some of these things of, you know,
maybe restaurants could figure out a way if
they're large enough, you reduce the capacity
by 80 percent and you let people without table
service just sit and have their takeout in
the restaurant.
These are the types of things that that need
to happen.
And then we want to start opening up some
other retail type businesses that may have
been closed.
But again, remember, many of those have been
open.
A lot of stuff hasn't actually been closed.
It's just been diminished.
And people are having to, you know, wear masks
when they are inside.
But those are some of the first steps I see.
But really, the steps that need to happen
before anything is actually opened is testing
that needs to increase dramatically and contact
tracing needs to increase them dramatically
until we have that opening is a real risk.